[Music]
it ridiculous rules news ridiculous
submitted by hello from Kauai oh come on
I've never been there before I want to
go so bad you know I heard that's the
best island really from who from the
clients Oh everyone tells me if you want
like nature and you can almost
experience the off-the-grid lifestyle I
just places with no running water and
stuff like that - yeah we don't we don't
get mud hut style nikki says it's for
hiking and I said pastor University
we're told not to use words like don't
or too many capital letters in
assignments oh because not everyone
types so you can't write us a you have
to write us and lowercase me too many
capital words bro you can't write NASA
no that's pretty because of youtube I
used to do that like I caught myself
doing that a couple times where I would
capitalize every word of the sentence
because the [ __ ] YouTube [ __ ] we'd
all do that for title type in caps lock
because I thought it looked cooler be
like why are you yelling at me
I couldn't yell enough I wanted to like
make the font even bigger if I can do
all assault no I would make it like
impact you know that that Joey I love
impact yeah and then I was the better I
think caps lock and I will bulb it and
then italicize it I used to like writing
capture than all the I's lowercase cuz I
like the little I thought it was oh
that's true
so anyway so yeah these journalism
professors at leave Trinity University
in the UK have been interrupted we try
not to use don't that much and then to
not write in all caps because it
frightens students oh that's the reason
why now you lost me where they don't
want to do the assignment I thought
because a lot of people use don't too
much and we should try to dial that back
if they put it like that I'd be like
okay maybe we're saying that students
anxiety can lead to academic failure and
so try not to use all caps I thought it
was a whole different thing because
they're finding out now that when you're
teaching a subject it's better to just
tell them what to do versus tell them
what not to do so for example like if
someone's giving you instruction on how
to shoot like a basketball you don't
tell them like don't tell don't don't
don't do it this way don't do it that
way you don't
do it that way right I'm saying it what
the word do as well don't overuse all of
them don't want to teach in dues because
you just want to forget all the things
that you're not supposed to do because
the brain will just start memorizing all
the bad things that you're not supposed
to do it will keep focusing on that are
you experiencing this with Isaac in his
school do they have this kind of like
the USA modeling I was calling but I
guess like just overprotective of
anxiety bitch-ass faculty that's the
technical term faculty this year I think
he's gotten a way tougher teacher than
he has like his entire schooling career
that's cuz he's going to a Asian school
well he has an Asian teacher for the
first time like way more strictly we got
his report card we were so shocked cuz
usually he gets like so they don't do
lips my letters they do my numbers so
it's like one two three four he usually
gets threes and fours mainly fours a
four isn't a weight they don't get me
see it what do you mean they don't get
these in season
well not in Isaac's school like
elementary school doesn't matter what a
is a four I yeah that makes sense it's
like a four point now if they're
straight A's is a 4.0 GPA mm-hmm but
then this one he got a whole bunch of
twos and threes really so we've been
smoking a cigarette in the alley - it
seems like a lot of this news is coming
from the UK yeah because they just
recently we also talked about that
Manchester University where they told
them not to clap anymore to use jazz
hands wait what's that one that's
causing like people with like auditory
anxiety like if everyone claps and it's
too lit everyone's like I support it cuz
it's funny as hell can you imagine
audience Superbowl audience and they're
gonna hear over time in the game winning
touchdown that was like I'm into that
man clapping is overrated dude it's been
done forever like well I'm ready for
something new it's so old why did we
skip snapping let's not see these
wrappings good that's hard to do gonna
innovate the class cloudiness
no no
for that and we still scream though is
it like no screaming that's the whole
auditory we need to change that spring
what if they're on to something though
like what if now they're creating like a
utopian like UK and we're all talking
[ __ ] like why nice all sensitive but now
they're all like mellow and chill right
and they get along you know like I'm not
stressed anymore
everyone's hella quiet but they're like
super stressed out yeah they're all
committing suicide well that's different
though because the work pressure and all
that [ __ ] is completely different
right and they also have their outlets
they have like days where they can dress
all crazy if they need to or they have
different clubs and bars for whatever
specific days yeah for whatever they
need my brother's an air traffic
controller and I'm like dude is that the
most stressful because everyone always
talked about how that's the most
stressful job yeah he's like no actually
you know what's great is that they love
us having a 764 in the tower and I'm
like yeah maybe are they joking no maybe
was it look at a communicate though cuz
they'll be like 20 planes waiting and
you still got to be like okay you come
in first you come in second you come in
third
but if he's like and then there's
[ __ ] my 20 Airlines yeah don't they
have like different like like it's like
a lane but in the air for them to like
fly it like a path well if I go back to
my knowledge of what I learned from like
die hard for doctor to fire to thank you
there's exactly three screens and
there's a guy that's telling them what
today and he's got a 1980s phone yeah
yes there was a documentary about that
stressful job and how there's early
deaths and people die like at a yeah
they're they're like in their fifties or
sixties or something and they can't it's
not a job that you could do for a long
time but this documentary was made in
the 90s before the onset of like our
tech yeah it's probably different now
I'm sure it is there's probably like way
less human error and [ __ ] you know if my
brother can do it anybody can do it no
he's the best I'm just like I don't know
man yeah
there's no way yeah I believe that all
is getting no he's a smart guy
it's just that he had topped with tough
time in school and then like you know we
all thought he wasn't gonna do [ __ ] with
his life that's for sure and then he
ended up being that mentality when I'm
training with people I get in a group
training session if I something starts
feeling hard and I like look over it on
my blog that little [ __ ] is doing it
what [ __ ] it a little bit you can do it
I could do I pick someone that I like I
feel like I'm a little bit tougher then
and if I could if they could do it that
I'm like I should be able to do this did
your mom ever tell you that when you
were little like you were scared of
something and then go like that little
kid okay that's the Asian wave you don't
do that opposite to this my mom picked
teachers for me and try to push me in
classes based off of racism so my mom
was my mom would be like okay genius if
she found out am I like fourth grade
class if one of the teachers was
Japanese you got to go with her she's
gonna be hard on you or German always
looking for the Japanese or the German
teacher cuz they're way more strict
where the footage you're the Axis powers
and [ __ ] do 23 Manship just look at that
last names okay give it like Lincoln
Berg yeah that's German she's like her
last names Rammstein it's like okay same
thing actually with tooth so you know
when we did the Spartan Race yeah but
she beat you though chose the wrong
person so did the monkey bars right she
went all the way across and I was like
look at my arms shrank my upper-body
strength compared to tips of her body
stress you could do pull-ups I could do
it yeah it's all in your head I didn't
think I could do it I got it I grabbed
the first one I was like oh my hands are
too small because tell you to I was like
[ __ ] I can do this so I was like I
actually did it I was like okay but it
was good that you were there I saw
you put tip down and do it I think you
just ran with like way past me and
finish before me I mean I can't run is
good but I could do monkey bars do you
don't even know how I finished that race
that's like at karate boot camp and I
seen these seven year olds know seven
years that [ __ ] that [ __ ] woke me up
like a [ __ ] I was like this
[ __ ] frail as geezer can do it and
he's better than me
bog do you know what's funny someone
messaged me when you made that statement
this man message means like don't sleep
on the other seven year olds and I'm
like I didn't even know cuz he watches
over 70 else to you dude my June read
karate where I took you know learned the
martial arts legend dude peace homie
tree was like he came doors all the time
and he would do he would use this frail
like eighty year old man even then and
that was like 20 years ago I swear to
god dude my grandpa they do look the
favor
it's absurd yeah so he would wear this
like gold ghee and then he would make us
all watch him do a hundred push-ups and
we're all just like well yeah but then
I'm like dude I could do [ __ ] a
hundred pushes with his old man can and
I couldn't do twenty a hundred straight
that shit's hard to know where yeah I
gotta take a break
yeah [ __ ] that but that Jesus Frank man
there's something hidden hidden in that
wrinkly ass muscle and when you're a
smaller person I feel like you can you
have so much strength because you're
just so small and [ __ ] I always because
I've always been been taller so I like I
was on the basketball team and should
have no [ __ ] coordination no like
your lever was it no no no no no no
people leverages but then you were
saying huh for basketball you sucked and
I'm like oh wait why was her oh I was
only on the team because I'm tall and I
was like tallest kid my school so they
boys put Mellon team but then I sucked
ass on the team so and I wouldn't have
coordination but I was always jealous
with the small kids like the [ __ ] did
they kick you off the team f know I
always got most improved cuz I suck so
hard that by the end of the year I could
dribble and they're like
on the varsity basketball team no I was
on University and we lost every game
we're yeah we're the Browns of our girls
like if you play basketball
how come we were playing basketball ads
house you're avoiding it and you're
complete on the opposite side of the
backyard and I'm like I don't think he
was on farce oh no I wasn't jump dead
like Dave if anyone was dribbling a
basketball Dave is gonna jump in like a
[ __ ] yeah not me David he wasn't
there he wasn't there I was flaky flaky
a usual yeah he flaky usually says show
up and then I and then I don't
participate you can't use your height
didn't know I could do rebounds all day
you just stand next to it and catch it
for everyone to ask me to shoot everyone
in vivo is tall so no good thing that he
was because he was taught away from what
I understood you were saying that
because you were tall you're
uncoordinated yeah sounds like kids who
have crazy growth spurts they don't have
the time to adjust to their limbs and
body if they're not like Harcourt
athletic then they they live life just
kind of like still trying to remember
and learn [ __ ] like but in the more
athletic you are the more you catch up
to you're like that range faster but I
was a sick PE quarterback not JV not
varsity flag girl I could bomb it down
the field and my buddy Mario would go
get it up every time I think he was just
good y'all be good at catch the use is
that good
I was just bothered out there and he
would get into my right through it it
was amazing I thought by the bathrooms
in that can we get it I miss football
[Music]